thanks to poor Bettany's portrayal of
the character in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe vision is now known to the
movie-going masses as a full-fledged
member of the Avengers but the
super-powerful synthezoid hasn't always
been a friend to Earth's Mightiest
arrows since his introduction in the
late 60s vision has been the focus of
some truly memorable arcs from his
undeniable similarities to a certain DC
character to his penchant for taking
over the planet he is everything Marvel
doesn't care for you to know about
vision not our vision the version of the
vision made popular by the MCU has been
around in the comics for several decades
now but he wasn't actually the first
character to use the name in November
1944 weeks before Captain America made
his debut an alien Lord keeper by the
name of arcus was introduced to the
Marvel Universe appearing through a
smoky portal in the pages of Marvel
mystery comics issue 13 after freezing a
mobster alive he introduced himself as
the vision and explained that had come
to earth to fight crime
his vigilantes breath didn't last very
long with the character making his last
appearance for some time in 1943 in 1968
a Marvel scribe Roy Thomas approached
Stanley about adding vision to the
Avengers lineup it grown frustrated and
not being able to use Marvel's heavy
hitters and wanted to bolster the ranks
of the neglected alien hero when Lee
said no Thomas source of went ahead and
just did it anyway using arcus as an
inspiration for a character of a
strikingly familiar name and luck Thomas
spoke to the magazine back issue in 2014
saying Stan wanted the new Avenger to be
an Android though we never said why I
split the difference and call the
Android division and adopted the old
costume but little else for the new
character Red Tornado watch the
similarities vision has with our curse /
intention off the things he has in
common with DC's Red Tornado that's a
different story if you aren't familiar
Red Tornado made his debut appearance in
Justice League of America issue 64 in
August 1968 two months before Marvel
introduced a new vision to Avengers
readers in the issue the Justice Society
of America is shocked when a robotic
version of the hero they once knew as a
different red tornado arrives at their
headquarters at first they're skeptical
of his motives but a mutual trust
emerges as they realized the big red guy
is on their side the parallels between
the Red Tornado and vision was striking
both had red skin and a high colored
cost
and both were created by a supervillain
to destroy a team of heroes that they
would promptly end up joining even
weirder both characters were Android
inspired reworkings of older comic book
characters of the same name will never
be 100% certain which of the characters
was created first for whatever reason
robots with emotions was one of 1968's
weird vibes double vision
well the arcus version of vision may
have inspired the vision we know the
original didn't stay gone in the early
90s roy thomas got his wish and was
finally given permission to bring arcus
back into the Marvel Universe the Golden
Age alien were turned to action in the
third issue of the invaders coming back
to do what he does best fight Nazis the
original vision continues to pop up from
time to time in modern Marvel Comics
helping out his allies from the Golden
Age whenever they need a hand
confusingly he's often still called a
vision instead of arcus even by
comic-book standards that makes things a
little complicated
I suppose disappointing logic and
emotion while vision comes off as one of
the most unique of the on-screen
Avengers his original creation was
heavily informed by contemporary sci-fi
according to Thomas visions personality
and temperament were inspired by the
character of Spock the half-human
half-vulcan first officer of the USS
Enterprise despite their superficial
differences both characters served the
same function their Wells have knowledge
that in spite of their outward coldness
of deep wells of compassion and longed
for acceptance another inspiration for
vision was AI robots a 1939 short by
osso and L bender with that story which
predated Isaac as a mobs version by
decades the brothers introduced a
character of Adam linked a self-aware
robot that Thomas calls one of the first
sympathetic robot stories over a series
of 10 tails Adam went to war
participated in sports was put on trial
and fought to be recognized as a
sentient citizen his ark helped pave the
way for countless sci-fi stories are
followed from age of Ultron sir well by
robot robots don't feel fear they don't
feel anything
they don't get hungry they don't sleep
idle I have even had dreams vanishing
act filmgoers already know the adorable
romance between vision and Scarlet Witch
they're two Outsiders with a romantic
connection and it's a relationship with
roots in the comics making them much
more than just Avengers with benefits
taking some time off from saving the
world the comic book couple married
moved to the suburbs and most puzzlingly
mate twins together that's right and
Doctor Strange even delivered the babies
seriously but how turns out when super
powers are involved life finds a way
Scala witches pregnancy came about
through a combination of a probability
altering hex powers and the literally
magic the fact that vision and Scarlet
Witch were able to conceive at all was a
little far-fetched even for comics and
their domestic bliss quickly turned to
psychological horror as it turns out
little Tommy and Billy were your
children but magical demonic hybrid
constructs fueled by scarlet witch's
powerful subconscious the ordeal
somewhat understandably temporarily
turned scarlet which completely insane
and her marriage to vision deteriorated
in the aftermath the two separated and
started operating on different Avengers
teams the clearest form of superhero
divorce eras while the event saw the
young family apart there was some
semblance of a happy ending years later
when Young Avengers introduced the
mutants Wiccan and speed the
incarnations of the twins who would
eventually meet their mom for real
visions of evil visions absurd power set
makes him a formidable hero to contend
with able to fly shoot lasers control
technology shape-shift phase through
solid matter heal himself and more he's
a source of character who could probably
take over the world if he wanted so in
classic what-if fashion Marvel's writers
have occasionally had him do just that
in 1985 Mighty Avengers issued 253
vision abandoned his physical form so he
could assume control of the world's
entire computer network and create a new
paradise on earth
The Avengers had started to become wary
of his odd behavior over the previous
few issues and were forced to stop him
before he got too powerful visions
actions led to the sim facade being
dismantled by government officials but
he wouldn't stay bits and pieces forever
vision has also been teased as a
powerful monster like when he was
recently compelled to join up with the
Hydra Avengers the team of heroes gone
bad that was featured in the 27
in crossover event secret Empire under
the control of an AI virus vision helped
a Hydra aligned Captain America that he
sets out on a mission to take over the
world on their evil organization's
behalf it's a scary situation for the
heroes when vision turns bad and hard
enough to deal with that doesn't happen
often
fortunately Paul Bettany vision seems
much too pure hearted for that unless of
course your name is Hawkeye or war
machine thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]